[Musique]
bienvenue à tous c'est reparti pour
paris saclay tv aujourd'hui c'est le ski
cube qui les accueillent c'est un
incubateur nouvelle génération il vient
tout juste d'être inauguré il va
accompagner des jeunes startups du
territoire de jeunes entrepreneurs qui
peuvent profiter de diverses
manifestations comme le paris saclay
invest un rendez vous qui se tient deux
fois par an et c'est l'occasion d'aller
à la rencontre des investisseurs
dix jeunes entreprises ont pu tenter
leur chance autre manifestation inédite
cette fois le haka tôt sur les mobilités
urbaines qui s'est déroulée au proto à
204 le pea paris saclay s'est associée à
nokia pour cet événement enfin toujours
dans cette volonté des changes
retour sur le 2ème tedx saclay des
intervenants de haut vol un public
passionné et un sujet ambitieux au delà
des limites et si vous aussi vous ne
voulez pas rater ces événements si vous
voulez assister et bien sûr tous ne
ratez pas notre agenda
ce sera à la fin de cette émission
nous voici au ski cube ce lieu vient
tout juste d'être inaugurée c'est un
incubateur nouvelle génération il va
héberger
dix jeunes startups objectif les
conseiller et les accompagner pour que
ces jeunes entrepreneurs ou
entrepreneuse puissent développer leurs
projets une initiative portée par jean
michel fourgous vice président en charge
du développement économique de saint
quentin en yvelines
nous l'avons rencontré
c'est le première étage de la fusée
donc c'est pour les jeunes entrepreneurs
les deux premières années donc
l'incubateur
c'est la première étape
l'incubateur au moment où on définit son
prototype 1 au moment où on n'a pas
encore rédigé son statut d'entreprise on
ne sait pas choisir des talents on sait
pas quels partenaires avant qu'on est là
pour leur apporter bien sûr toutes les
informations on l'aimé à une vingtaine
d'entrepreneurs où ils échangent
ensemble en plus ils se posent les mêmes
questions
ils ont un animateur en plus ils ont un
cube alliance qui est un spécialiste
français de l'incubation ils ont des
locaux sympathique ça nous a coûté 23
millions c'est presque un demi million
après de fonctionnement nous voyons on
met le paquet et ils ont toutes les
conditions ils ont un réseau sur tout un
réseau d'entrepreneurs de très haute
qualité
c'est festif inauguré ici donc de 51
saclay c'est une nuise au mondial
d'innovation bien sûr il ya eu un très
bon niveau d'entrepreneurs donc
d'interlocuteurs pour eux
et même éventuellement de clients on les
met dans les meilleures conditions pour
accélérer et raccourcir la durée de
création moi j'ai créé mon entreprise en
avril seuls j'ai eu des difficultés pour
déposer un brevet pour le protéger pour
trouver des fonds pour faire le premier
crédit impôt recherche pour créer une
production un distributeur pour exporter
et bien toutes ces questions là elles
sont concentrés on les aide à raccourcir
ce délai peut-être de 2 3 ans je pense
que c'est un accélérateur vraiment de
croissance pour eux on a une entreprise
sur deux est quasiment qui se casse la
figure dans les cinq premières années
ben là on est là pour les structurer et
bien sûr à accélérer leurs réussites et
les conforter
bien sûr cette réussite sur des marchés
aussi qu'ils sont
enfant croissance donc on appelait les
grandes conditions
donc c'est bien parti et bien sûr on est
passionné par ce projet ce ski cube
s'inscrit dans une dynamique celle de
l'innovation de l'emploi ensuite nos
jeunes entrepreneurs doivent se faire
connaître trouver des investisseurs et
c'est tout l'enjeu de paris saclay une
veste une manifestation qui se tient
maintenant deux fois par an nous avons
assisté à la dernière session c'était à
hec à jouy en josas
aujourd'hui nous sommes à hec le
financement et des chose de très
important
c'est important pour l'animation de
l'innovation et des jeunes entreprises
innovantes du territoire paris saclay
c'est une marque qui se destine à être
une marque très important devant de
l'innovation même au niveau mondial et
le fait d'organiser à deux reprises dans
l'année
cet événement effectivement permet
d'accompagner déjà détecté les start-ups
qu'il ya de nombreuses créations
d'entreprises innovantes sur le
territoire cet événement permet de
détecter et de les aider à trouver leur
financement du sprint c'est une borne
qui vous permet d'imprimer
instantanément et sur place ou les aux
vacances vos propres cartes postales à
partir de vos photos de smartphones
voilà le principe c'est de restituer en
fait tous les toulousains de la hure de
la carte postale classique qui est un
acte spontané le plaisir de l'écriture
est un objet qui voyage mais en ajoutant
une valeur supplémentaire qui est la
personnalisation de la carte et donc de
faire de la carte un véritable support
de sa vision du voyage
aujourd'hui c'est une immense
opportunité pour nous de présenter notre
projet à plusieurs investisseurs
et puis on a donc un stand où on peut
les rencontrer après notre présentation
on est exactement dans la phase où on a
besoin d'être accompagnés financièrement
et de tester notre projet auprès de gens
qui vont investir les investisseurs ont
recherché des business angels vont être
capables
de nous accompagner financièrement mais
aussi de nous accompagner avec leur
expertise leurs compétences et puis leur
réseau on attend aussi beaucoup là
dessus nous notre tour c'est qu'il ya
vraiment une grande activité autour des
starters on me sens depuis quelques
années que tout le monde souhaite que
des start-up émergent en france ces
stars tablas qui ont créé l'avenir et du
coup on a plein d'opportunités de se
mettre en avant
alors aujourd'hui un événement comme ça
c'est un exemple mais on a plein
d'autres événements notamment dans les
yvelines pour présenter notre projet
donc c'est dynamique
à force de travail on est capable de
trouver de séduire les mains
d'investisseurs
autre grand rendez vous en cette fin
d'année un haka ton sur les mobilités
urbaines c'était une première et ça
s'est passé au proto 204 il s'agissait
de réfléchir sur les mouvements les flux
ceux des hommes aussi ceux des objets ou
encore les transports un événement
organisé par l'établissement public
paris saclay et nokia regarde
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a la chance d'organiser
au proto 204 à 4 qui est un concours de
programmation dont le thème est comment
on va détecter les mouvements au sein
d'une cité intelligente comme le plateau
de sacrée et donc ça va durer sur deux
jours ici on va accueillir et des
étudiants de liliane stm et le grand
public des hackers n'importe qui peut
venir pour proposer une solution à base
de programmation pour résoudre ce
challenge il travaille sur le thème des
objets connectés
donc comment on peut faire dans une
ville intelligente pour détecter du
mouvement pour répondre à des
problématiques autour ce sujet là avec
des objets connectés donc typiquement
les étudiants qui nous accompagne
aujourd'hui ont à leur disposition des
kits de développement des caméras et des
librairies de programmation qui leur
permettent de détecter un mouvement
ce qui nous intéresse nous chez nokia au
travers ce projet c'est de voir comment
on peut demain améliorer le plateau de
saclay avec un réseau une infrastructure
une plateforme et des solutions
concrètes des objets connectés qui sont
capables de faire ça des exemples
d'applications très simple par exemple
c'est de détecter des personnes dans un
abribus pour optimiser le trajet des bus
et améliorer les phases de récupération
des personnes c'est de détecter les flux
des voitures pour optimiser le trafic ce
genre de choses on a mis à disposition
un certain nombre de ressources
également des mentors qui peuvent les
aider à avancer dans leurs projets à la
fin de la journée il y aura un pitch
dans lequel ils ont expliqué leur projet
et éventuellement d'entrée un prototype
la journée de demain est dédié au public
il commence d'ailleurs dès ce soir où
les gens pourront venir commencé à coder
venir commencé à travailler sur leurs
idées et demain soir sera remis un prix
à la meilleure idée qui aurait été
sélectionnés par un jury dont nous sont
partis
il
à paris saclay toutes les occasions sont
bonnes pour se retrouver pour échanger
réfléchir sur la vie ou la ville de
demain
même au delà des limites c'était le
sujet ambitieux du dernier tedx saclay
le deuxième du genre
et parmi les intervenants des étudiants
une nouveauté est une évidence pour acea
van gijzel fondatrice créatrice de tedx
s'appelait
[Musique]
l'année dernière on avait fait une
première édition sur les lumières comme
c'était le thème est cette deuxième
édition elle est sûre au delà des
limites
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer des
personnes et je me suis rendu compte
qu'il ya deux types de population il ya
des personnes qui qui restent cantonnés
dans leur zone de confort il ya des
personnes qui font des choix différents
et ses choix exige de sortir du chemin
connu donc au delà limite pour moi c'est
repoussé les limites du connu et
décloisonnée décloisonner entre des
disciplines pour moi je t'ai dit
s'appeler s'est créé des coûts dans
paris 7 les et au delà des limites
une fois qu'on a enlevé les pombas en
repousse ses limites mais tous ensemble
dans les profils il ya un peu de tout en
fait le premier c'est un scientifique
qui est aussi philosophe il ya thierry
marx qui est un chef étoilé mais c'est
vrai un quelqu'un qui s'est fait par lui
même c'est un parcours personnel et ya
raphaël haumont fera un bel lui c'est
c'est un chimiste qui est passionné par
la matière enfin donc en fait il ya des
chercheurs entrepreneurs artistes et des
aventuriers comme avec ghislain bardot
pour un des deux pôles les 12 minutes
c'était un conseil d'alsace en stage
donc c'est l'entreprise avec qui on
travaille qui fait le coaching des
intervenants parce qu'ils ont remarqué
que sur une durée de 12 minutes la vidéo
sur youtube a plus de chance d'être
écoutés entendus
donc ça c'est des statistiques eux ils
ont enfin et je trouve que ça donne du
dynamisme c'est à dire qu'on a gardé le
même timing par rapport à l'année
dernière sauf quand on a 12 intervenants
lieu de 10 et je pense que c'est même un
challenge pour les intervenants faire le
même discours entre en 12 minutes au
lieu de 15 cd dire qu'il faut qu'ils
aillent au coeur du message et ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on recherchait le
public était absorbé il ya eu des
moments de rire et des moments très
forts de concentration et et ça pour moi
c'est une belle mesure
je suis très très heureuse parce que
quand on l'a vu la salle on s'est dit
c'est un challenge est ce qu'on va voir
réussir à remplir la salle pour la
deuxième édition
c'était le cas c'est complet et puis
beaucoup de lieux des icônes hector et
tout ça qui nous ont suivis qui ont
parlé de l'événement qui ont clients qui
sont venus assister à nos réunions
mensuelles avec les et connecteurs les
partenaires on en a 19 cette année il y
en a d'autres qui arrivent je pense que
c'est un succès mais j'en suis convaincu
je ne pense pas
et voilà si vous aussi vous avez envie
de participer à ces événements et bien
prenez vos agendas si le moment le
comité de suivi de chantier sur le
quartier de l'école polytechnique il est
prévu le lundi 16 janvier de 17h30 à 19h
au plateau des projets venez nombreux on
vous attend voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci à vous de l'avoir suivi
paris saclay tv vous fait vivre
l'actualité de votre territoire mais
d'ici là restez connectés une seule
adresse pop ups point fr
[Musique]